good evening 9-1-1 calls obtained by the
i-team are shedding more light on a
high-profile northwest valley murder
case
thanks for joining us at 11 i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis a 16 year
old girl and her 18 year old boyfriend
accused
of killing her father 45 year old daniel
halsett and tonight
we hear the moments leading up to police
discovering the body
arc oh manna joining us now live from
the home where he was found with the
details of those 9-1-1 calls
orca well denise and brian
both 9-1-1 calls were made on april 9.
the first caller was daniel houssett's
mother who was trying to find her son
and the second caller says they found
helset's body
inside the garage of this home here on
dunphy court which is near west cliff
and durango
we want to note these calls may be tough
to listen to
he just doesn't do this stuff this is
what's so weird a mother
concerned for her son's safety in a 911
call from april 9
obtained by 8 news now the mother of 45
year old las vegas daniel helseth says
he had been missing for a couple days
she wanted police to do a welfare check
i've called his ex-wife called and
there's nobody answering the phone and
nobody is there's
nothing also unusual she says her son's
debit card was used at three different
atms and how seth's daughter was not
answering text messages
i said you know i really need to talk to
dan or your dad
i'm concerned about him and
she didn't respond i know there's
something very wrong going on here
another 911 call that same day came from
someone who says they discovered house
that's burned body inside the home
the caller shocked by what they were
seeing there was a fire
and we went in to investigate the fire
must be a couple days old
but there's a dead body in the garage we
just found i'm with the homeowner that
doesn't live here
daniel halseth's daughter 16 year old
sierra halsoth and her boyfriend 18 year
old aaron guerrero were arrested in salt
lake city utah
metro police tell us the teen set a fire
to try and cover up the crime scene and
they also tried to dismember the
victim's body
both teens are in custody here in clark
county they face murder charges
and are expected to appear in court
tomorrow reporting live in las vegas
tonight orco mana 8 news now